My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。让我感到惊讶的是，通往这一职业的道路竟有如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that,
但相信我，一旦你开始读，就绝对放不下这本书。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。让我感到惊讶的是，通往这一职业的道路竟有如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我充满信心，意识到
no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. A lot of psychologists are wondering the same thing right now. What would my life look like if I worked somewhere else? Different system, different culture, different pace. I'm Dr. Marianne and I've spent years supporting psychologists through training, burnout
我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，就绝对放不下这本书。现在很多心理学家都在思考同样的问题：如果我在别的地方工作，我的生活会是什么样？不同的体制、不同的文化、不同的节奏。我是Marianne博士，多年来我一直致力于在心理学家的培训、职业倦怠
and big career decisions. In this episode, I'm speaking with Dr Jack, a UK trained psychologist who moved from South London to working clinically in the UAE. We're asking the kinds of questions people don't always get clear answers to so you can fill in your own knowledge gaps, understand the realities and feel better informed whether you're considering the move yourself or just supporting someone who is. This isn't about selling the dream. about understanding the decision. I hope you find it so useful and if you do like and subscribe for more.
以及重大职业决策方面提供支持。在这一集中，我采访了Jack博士，他是一位在英国受训的心理学家，从伦敦南部搬到了阿联酋从事临床工作。我们探讨了人们通常无法获得明确答案的问题，这样你就可以填补自己的知识空白，了解现实情况，并无论你是自己考虑搬迁，还是仅仅在支持他人，都能做出更明智的决定。这并不是在兜售梦想，而是在理解这一决定。希望你觉得这很有用，如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。
Hi, I just want to welcome along Dr Jack Nejan to the podcast. Hi Jack, welcome along. Hi, Mariam. Thanks for having me. Could you tell us a little bit about kind of a very brief potted history for you, how you became a clinical psychologist, if that's okay, Jack? of course yeah um so i chose psychologists in a level that was my first kind of entry into psychology or even being interested in psychology i think because i enjoyed other subjects at school such as maths english science etc but i wanted an a level that kind of combined those things but it was a little bit different a bit of a wild card i suppose um and just really fell in love of learning about the classical studies that you learn at a level,
嗨，我想欢迎Jack Nejan博士来到播客。嗨，Jack，欢迎你。嗨，Marian，谢谢邀请。Jack，你能简单介绍一下你的职业历程，谈谈你是如何成为临床心理学家的吗？当然可以。嗯，我在A-Level阶段选择了心理学，那是我第一次接触心理学，或者说对心理学产生兴趣，我想是因为我当时在学校里喜欢数学、英语、科学等其他科目，但我想要一门能结合这些学科，又有点不同、有点“出人意料”的课程。嗯，我真的爱上了学习A-Level阶段那些经典的心理学研究，
understanding a bit more about things that may be, at least my parents' generation and people that I would be talking to about, my studies didn't really understand or know too much about. So that inspired my interest in psychology and wanting to do it at an undergraduate degree. But I hadn't really considered clinical psychology as a career until maybe my third year of undergrad when I did a placement. I knew that I liked working with young people because I'd had a few roles in schools and tuition centres
对那些可能——至少是我父母那一代人以及我与之交流的人——不太了解或知之甚少的事情有了更深入的理解。这激发了我对心理学的兴趣，并促使我想要攻读心理学本科。但在大三实习之前，我并没有真正考虑过将临床心理学作为职业。我知道我喜欢与年轻人一起工作，因为我曾在学校和补习中心担任过一些职务，
and places like that where I was supporting young people with their education. And so when the opportunity to do a year in industry came along, I thought I would apply to Great Ormond Street, which had really good connections with the University of Bath where I was studying. I was fortunate to get a placement there for a year and spent most of that observing some really fantastic psychologists who really welcomed us into their work and allowed us to be in the room with them when they were doing
以及类似的地方，在那里我为年轻人的教育提供支持。所以，当有机会进行为期一年的行业实习时，我想申请大奥蒙德街医院（Great Ormond Street），因为它与我当时就读的巴斯大学有很好的联系。我很幸运在那里获得了一年的实习机会，大部分时间都在观察一些非常出色的心理学家，他们非常欢迎我们参与他们的工作，并允许我们在他们进行
kind of really important second opinion. Autism assessments, cognitive assessments or so on. From there really, I just decided that's a path I wanted to pursue. So after that, I spent quite a few months following graduation, applying for assistant psychologist roles, took a bit of time, as I'm sure most people, people have that experience, but managed to get a role in a brain injury rehab unit in South East London and got a lot of responsibility and experience there as well. So again,
一些非常重要的第二意见评估、自闭症评估、认知评估等工作时，在现场旁听。从那时起，我就决定这是我想追求的道路。毕业后，我花了几个月的时间申请助理心理学家的职位，过程有点漫长，我相信大多数人都有过这种经历，但我最终在伦敦东南部的一家脑损伤康复中心获得了一个职位，在那里我也获得了很大的责任和经验。所以同样地，
had a really fantastic supervisor who thrust me into the deep end a lot of the time, but not without the support that I needed to then kind of successfully apply for training. So I started training in 2018. And yeah, that's kind of where the journey to being officially. Shereka and Korsiqa just began. Amazing. Thank you. So I know that will have encapsulated the pandemic, but we probably don't have time to quite do that justice right now, but as we can all imagine kind of what that was like for a trainee,
我有一位非常出色的主管，他经常让我承担重任，但同时也提供了我所需的必要支持，让我能够成功申请到培训。所以我于2018年开始接受培训。是的，这就是成为正式心理学家的旅程的开始。太棒了，谢谢。我知道这其中涵盖了疫情期间，但我们现在可能没有时间详细展开，不过我们可以想象这对实习生来说意味着什么，
and there were certain other episodes of the podcast where we have discussed that with previous guests. So you then started working in a CAM service as a qualified psychologist and worked there for a number of years. When did the idea of moving a... abroad and practicing as a clinical psychologist kind of first arise? It's a good question, really. I think after a couple of years of being in the service, which I loved, I had some great colleagues there and again had lots of opportunities for kind of higher
而且播客的其他几期节目中，我们也曾与之前的嘉宾讨论过这一点。那么，你后来作为一名合格的心理学家在CAMHS（儿童与青少年心理健康服务）工作了几年。你是什么时候开始萌生去国外以临床心理学家的身份执业的想法的？这是一个很好的问题。我想在服务机构工作了几年后，我非常喜欢那里，我有很棒的同事，而且再次获得了许多机会，承担了比我在其他服务机构中可能允许的
responsibility than perhaps my role would otherwise allow in other services. I guess I was aware of the connections between Slam, South London and Morsley Trust, where I was working, and a service called Morsley Health that exists here in the UAE. And so as a case of exploring what a role out here might look like, talking to people who are already here and just understanding what it's like day to day on a personal level and a professional level. And once I'd spoken to the team lead in my service, she was very helpful in getting me in touch with,
更高的责任。我想我当时了解SLaM（南伦敦和莫兹利信托基金会）与阿联酋的一家名为Maudsley Health的服务机构之间的联系。所以，这成了一个探索在那边工作会是什么样子的过程，通过与已经在那里的人交谈，从个人和职业层面了解日常工作的情况。当我与我所在服务机构的团队负责人交谈后，她非常热心地帮我联系了
I guess, the more important people at Morsley Health who could talk to me about a potential role and so on. I guess it was a combination of factors, but having that link already made it feel a bit easier and a bit more familiar if I was to make that move, knowing that there's professional opportunities. And I guess a lot of the other things that come with being in a job for a long time, thinking about progression, improving my financial situation, I suppose. That's important to shy away from that point. And just maybe going somewhere where the weather was a bit nicer and the culture was different. and just getting all those experiences at stage in my life where it felt kind of possible still. Yeah, I mean, I'm sitting here with a hot water bottle on my lap under my blanket,
Maudsley Health那边更重要的人，他们可以和我谈谈潜在的职位等等。我想这是多种因素的结合，但有了那层联系，如果我要搬过去，会感觉更容易、更熟悉一些，因为我知道那里有职业发展机会。我想还有很多长期从事一份工作所带来的其他考量，比如考虑职业晋升、改善财务状况，我想这一点很重要，不必回避。也许还可以去一个天气更好、文化不同的地方，在人生中感觉还有可能性的阶段，获得所有这些经历。是的，我的意思是，我现在正坐在毯子下，腿上放着热水袋，
which you can't see, it's just off camera, and you're sitting there with the aircon on near the beach. So, yes, we could definitely see that there are differences in our current experiences. Am I right in thinking that, I know Dubai, I think, is tax-free, is where you are tax-free as well? Yeah, so there's no income tax, salary is paid in full. I suppose where that comes around is that there are lots of other things in day-to-day life that perhaps are either more expensive or are taxed in kind of other ways. So it's not that it's completely tax-free as a country, but certainly with income tax, that's a significant advantage to working out here.
你看不见，就在镜头外，而你坐在海边开着空调。所以，是的，我们确实能看出我们目前的经历存在差异。我理解得对吗？我知道迪拜，我想，是免税的，你所在的地方也是免税的？是的，没有所得税，工资全额发放。我想这其中的平衡在于，日常生活中有很多其他东西可能更贵，或者以其他方式征税。所以并不是说这个国家完全免税，但就所得税而言，这确实是在这里工作的一个显著优势。
Absolutely. And especially if you wanted to kind of save up for a period of to then buy property elsewhere or live a life that just felt, I don't know, more aligned to your own goals and values that does make it easier. What's it like when you sort of say to friends, family, loved ones, I am thinking of, you know, moving my entire life to UAE. What was that like for you? I'd say on the whole a positive experience, but not without trepidation, not wanting to perhaps accept people or just knowing that people will have a certain reaction depending on their relationship with you. So certainly telling close family, you know, that was hard because of, apart from being at
绝对是。特别是如果你想存钱，以便以后在别处买房，或者过上一种感觉更符合你个人目标和价值观的生活，这确实让事情变得更容易。当你告诉朋友、家人、爱人“我正在考虑搬到阿联酋生活”时，那是什么感觉？总的来说，这是一次积极的经历，但并非没有忐忑，不想让人们失望，或者只是知道人们会根据与你的关系而有不同的反应。所以告诉亲近的家人确实很难，因为除了在
bath for three years, doing my undergraduate degree, I've always been very close to where my parents live and been able to see them very frequently. And my, you know, my extended family are all nearby in kind of South London as well. So, yeah, that was certainly a difficult conversation, but my family, very supportive and it certainly made the process a lot easier once it was out on the open. Similarly telling friends as well, I think it's been quite well documented in the news even. I think there's a lot of people around my age, coming early 30s or even late 20s, who are making the move at the moment either to places like the UAE or Australia or parts of
巴斯读了三年本科之外，我一直离父母住的地方很近，能经常见到他们。而且我的大家庭也都住在伦敦南部附近。所以，是的，那确实是一次艰难的谈话，但我的家人非常支持，一旦公开了，整个过程确实变得容易多了。同样地，告诉朋友也是如此，我想这在新闻中已经有很好的记录了。我想我这个年纪，刚过30岁甚至不到30岁的人中，有很多正在考虑搬迁，无论是去阿联酋、澳大利亚还是
Europe and so on, just seeking something that perhaps they feel they're not getting by being in the UK at the moment. I guess there's a lot of financial pressure the cost of living crisis and so on. It's just made people think twice about what's possible at a stage in their life. So friends perhaps more understanding initially and quite a few of them have actually been making similar moves in the last few years. So maybe that felt more normal. It's something we're all getting used to is being more connected on WhatsApp
欧洲等地，只是在寻求一种他们觉得目前在英国无法获得的东西。我想有很多财务压力、生活成本危机等等。这让人们重新思考在人生的这个阶段什么才是可能的。所以朋友们起初可能更理解，事实上，过去几年里他们中也有不少人做出了类似的搬迁决定。所以也许这感觉更正常了。我们都在习惯的一件事就是通过WhatsApp保持更紧密的联系，
at different hours of the day because of time zone differences and stuff like that. So yeah, on the whole it was a positive experience. I'm pleased to hear it, Jack. And it reminds me of a news article I heard on the radio a couple of weeks ago that made me think of you, actually, because it was saying that for the first time ever, actually when they're looking at migration figures, it isn't kind of people of retirement age heading to sunny Spain
因为时差等原因。所以，总的来说，这是一次积极的经历。很高兴听到这些，Jack。这让我想起了几周前我在广播里听到的一篇新闻文章，它确实让我想到了你，因为它说这是有史以来第一次，当他们查看移民数据时，从英国移居海外的人群中，最大的群体不再是退休年龄前往阳光明媚的西班牙的人，
that are the biggest chunk of people becoming expats from the UK. It's actually people in your age bracket. And they were kind of looking at the wise and where, forwards of that, but exactly as you said, like maybe people are not necessarily feeling the same level of hope or, or kind of that they can achieve in the UK for whatever reason. And I'm not saying that's right or wrong. This is just what was discussed in the news. And I guess the sense that life is for living, but also this doesn't necessarily have to be forever. So it might be. So one of my friends' brothers actually went out to the UAE.
而是你这个年龄段的人。他们分析了原因和去向，但正如你所说，也许人们并不一定感到同样的希望，或者因为某种原因觉得在英国无法实现自我。我并不是说这是对还是错，这只是新闻中讨论的内容。我想这是一种“人生苦短，及时行乐”的感觉，但这并不一定意味着要永远待在那里。所以可能是这样。我一个朋友的兄弟实际上去了阿联酋。
U-A-E. I keep mixing it up because it's a university I speak about quite often, but UAE and ended up meeting someone getting married and they've now got two sons out there. So, and even about I moved to Coventry
阿联酋（UAE）。我总是把它搞混，因为我经常提到一所大学，但UAE，他最终在那里遇到了某人并结婚了，现在他们在那边有两个儿子。所以，甚至关于我搬到考文垂
for three years and I'm still here married with two sons. You know, sometimes the decisions we make for kind of just now or for a period in our life do become more permanent and become the fabric of our lives. But yeah, I'm really pleased to hear that you found that to be, a good experience and how's it been since you've been there?
住了三年，我现在还在这里，结婚并有两个儿子。你知道，有时我们为了当下或人生某个阶段所做的决定，确实会变得更加永久，成为我们生活的底色。但是，是的，我很高兴听到你觉得这是一次很好的经历，自从你搬过去之后，情况如何？
On the whole, again, very positive, I think it's probably an old cliche, but just waking up with the sun shining every day, it does make quite a big difference and I compare that to this time last year, as much as I loved the clinical work I was doing, lots of early starts in the dark, driving in the cold and wet to, you know, out to Essex or getting the train into the southeast London or whatever to go to schools and we'll do work there. So in that respect, I guess that's something that's quite tangible and easy to notice as a difference from arrival of straight away. Say on the whole though, you know, moving in general can be quite stressful and there's lots of admin and things to keep track of and so on. So moving countries, me doing it for the first time,
总的来说，还是非常积极的。我想这可能是一个老生常谈的陈词滥调，但每天醒来阳光明媚，确实带来了很大的不同。我把它与去年这个时候相比，尽管我当时很热爱我的临床工作，但有很多在黑暗中早起、在寒冷潮湿的天气里开车去埃塞克斯，或者坐火车去伦敦东南部去学校做工作的情况。所以在这方面，我想这是从抵达那一刻起就能明显感受到的差异。不过总的来说，搬家通常会让人感到压力很大，有很多行政事务和琐事需要处理。所以搬到另一个国家，我第一次这样做，
I guess, has made me realise quite how much goes into it, how much thought and how much energy you're left with afterwards. So I'm still very much in that transitional phase. My lifestyle and the things that I want to be doing with my time aren't necessarily in place just yet, but I'm kind of building bit by bit. So yeah, and everyone that I've met, kind of colleagues, other people that I've met through playing football, for example, and just trying to to meet people organically, I guess, that have been really helpful. Everyone offers their number very quickly. It doesn't happen so much in the UK in case you've got questions. about little things like how does this work or how much it costs, whatever it might be.
我想，让我意识到这需要投入多少精力，以及事后会剩下多少思考和能量。所以我还处于那个过渡阶段。我的生活方式以及我想用时间做的事情还不一定完全到位，但我正在一点一点地建立起来。所以，是的，我遇到的每个人，比如同事，通过踢足球认识的其他人，以及试图自然地结识朋友，我想，他们都非常有帮助。每个人都很快提供他们的电话号码，以防你有问题。这在英国不太常见，比如关于小事情，比如这个怎么运作，或者它要花多少钱，无论是什么。
So yeah, it's been a really positive experience so far. Yeah, that was going to be my next question, really. How easily you'd found it to kind of set up hobbies, whether you've kind of developed new ones, kind of beach living or whether you've kind of reconnected with old ones or whether you're just seeing how it all unfolds really because that is, I think, so important to our well-being. I was wondering whether, you know, there's theatres, you know, nightlife. I'm guessing there is, but like, you know, how easy is it to set things up around you to support your well-being so that you can thrive? Yes, a really good question.
所以，是的，到目前为止这是一次非常积极的经历。是的，那本来是我要问的下一个问题。你发现建立爱好有多容易，你是开发了新的爱好，比如海滩生活，还是重新连接了旧的爱好，或者你只是在顺其自然，因为我认为这对我们的幸福感非常重要。我很好奇，那里有剧院、夜生活吗？我猜是有的，但你周围建立支持你幸福感的事物有多容易，这样你才能茁壮成长？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。
It's something I reflect on quite a lot with people who are asking me how the process is going, who've not, you know, long been through the process themselves with my partner as well. I think they reached a point maybe a month ago when we'd been here for three, months. I kind of decided, you know, I'm not doing enough exercise and I'm not meeting enough people yet. So I'm just going to go for it and join a football team. So that's only happened quite recently, but I think it's relatively easy to find these spaces. If you want them, you know, Aberdub is a very, very busy city. There's lots and lots of social stuff going on, even just following a few social media pages to see what's about can give you ideas every single weekend
我经常与那些问我进展如何、自己还没有经历过这个过程的人，以及我的伴侣反思这一点。我想大约一个月前，当我们在这里待了三个月时，我决定，我锻炼得不够，还没认识足够多的人。所以我决定豁出去了，加入了一支足球队。所以这只是最近才发生的事情，但我认为找到这些空间相对容易。如果你想要的话，迪拜是一个非常非常繁忙的城市。有很多很多的社交活动，即使只是关注几个社交媒体页面看看有什么活动，每个周末都能给你带来灵感，
are completely different. So there's everything out there if you want it to happen. The opportunities are there and I guess it's just down to individual preference as to how much you engage with that, how quickly you engage with that. And also I guess financially, like how much money you're ready to commit to a new hobby, for example. But I've enjoyed the process of learning what's out there, what's available. Certainly, as you mentioned, kind of having the chance to spend more time on the beach or be in the sea or swim or whatever it might be that wasn't on my radar whatsoever living in south-west London for the last couple of years. So yeah, I'm looking forward to that seeing how it goes and kind of trying to build things up gradually so that I'm not being too
完全不同。所以如果你想让它发生，那里什么都有。机会就在那里，我想这取决于个人的偏好，你参与的程度，你参与的速度。还有我想在经济上，你准备为一项新爱好投入多少钱，例如。但我很享受了解那里有什么、有什么可用的过程。当然，正如你提到的，有机会花更多时间在海滩上，或者在海里，或者游泳，无论是什么，这在我过去几年住在伦敦西南部时根本不在我的考虑范围内。所以，是的，我很期待看到进展如何，并尝试逐渐建立起来，这样我就不会感到太
overwhelmed or like, you know, I'm not ready to make that change or that adaptation when even getting used to the workplace and how everything's different. There is also a challenge of itself. And so it sounds like you and your partner kind of made this plan together and Do you move out together and kind of built life and found kind of jobs together? I'm guessing that helps combat loneliness as well because I know some people move out by themselves. It's kind of all or nothing, isn't it? It's all on them to create stuff around them and you don't kind of have the Netflix and still have some company kind of vibe that you might be used to at home.
不知所措，或者说，我还没有准备好做出那种改变或适应，当连习惯工作场所和一切事物的不同本身就是一种挑战时。听起来你和你的伴侣是一起制定了这个计划，你们是一起搬过去，一起建立生活并找到工作的吗？我猜这也有助于对抗孤独感，因为我知道有些人是独自搬过去的。这有点像“要么全有，要么全无”，对吧？一切都得靠自己去创造周围的事物，而且你可能没有那种在家里习惯的“一边看Netflix一边有人陪伴”的氛围。
Yeah, exactly. So we moved out together, although we had various plans before that, dependent on whether she was able to get a job before coming or not. Different job markets vary in terms of, I guess, how many opportunities there are, how many vacancies there are and stuff. So she's been looking since she arrived. But she actually grew up here, so that was a big factor in deciding to move over and something that she'd been considering, I think even before we'd met.
是的，完全正确。所以我们是一起搬过去的，尽管在那之前我们有各种计划，取决于她是否能在来之前找到工作。不同的就业市场在机会数量、职位空缺数量等方面各不相同。所以她自抵达以来一直在寻找。但她实际上是在这里长大的，所以这是决定搬过来的一大因素，也是她在我们认识之前就一直在考虑的事情。
So once I'd have a chance to visit a few years ago for a friend's wedding and get a sense of what it's like here, is then a case of, of, I guess, gathering all the information I heard about what living here would look like as opposed to just coming on holiday. But yeah, it has been nice, certainly, to do that alongside somebody else. And obviously share all the joys, but also the frustrations. And I feel like you're going too crazy when something completely far-fetched happens that you just never would expect to happen back home.
所以当我几年前有机会去那里参加朋友的婚礼，并对这里的情况有所了解后，我就开始收集我听到的关于在这里生活的信息，而不是仅仅来度假。但是，是的，能和另一个人一起做这件事确实很好。显然可以分享所有的快乐，也可以分享挫折。我觉得当你遇到一些完全不可思议的事情，而你在家里根本想不到会发生时，你会觉得快疯了。
Absolutely. I'm sure there's lots of cultural shocks and things that you're just not used to and you're having to adjust to. And one of those, I think I'm right in saying that in the past people who are not married that are living together or, you know, might kiss or hold hands outside in Arab countries, that's kind of not always okay. I don't know if you are married and how that's been for you, but if someone is looking at kind of thinking about whether they might move, is that a consideration for them, Jack, do you know? So we're not married and the rules around cohabitation changed I think just before COVID so you know expatriate couples are certainly allowed to live together without being married so that wasn't an issue thankfully I think yeah there's still some cultural expectations around you know things like displays of
绝对是。我相信有很多文化冲击和你不习惯的事情，你必须去适应。其中之一，我想我没说错的话，过去在阿拉伯国家，未婚同居，或者在公共场合接吻或牵手，是不太被允许的。我不知道你是否结婚了，这对你来说情况如何，但如果有人正在考虑是否要搬过去，Jack，你知道这是否是他们需要考虑的问题吗？我们没有结婚，关于同居的规定我想是在新冠疫情前改变的，所以外籍伴侣当然可以在未婚的情况下住在一起，所以谢天谢地，那不是问题。我想，是的，仍然存在一些文化期望，比如在公共场合表现出
affection in public and so on I wouldn't say that's been a concern or an issue for us or something we've had to think too consciously about. I think things like handholding aren't, aren't particularly frowned upon or anything like that. And I think from a legal standpoint, it's less to do with, you know, the potential punishment or anything like that. It's more so just about kind of respecting the boundaries of the people that are around and so on. But it's also a very multicultural society. So only about just over 10% of the population here are actually native to the country. They're actually kind of locals and then the rest is made up of expatriates from all over the world or with different cultures and expectations and beliefs and so on and so yeah I guess being
亲昵等等，我不会说这对我们来说是一个担忧或问题，或者我们需要太刻意去考虑的事情。我认为像牵手这样的事情并不是特别令人反感。而且我认为从法律角度来看，这与潜在的惩罚无关。更多的是关于尊重周围人的界限等等。但这也是一个非常多元文化的社会。所以这里只有大约10%多一点的人口是本地人，他们是当地人，其余的都是来自世界各地的外籍人士，有着不同的文化、期望和信仰等等。所以，是的，我想
clued up is important but I don't feel fortunately in any way that I've had to be you know uber vigilant or conscious of specific things that I would be doing in the UK that I can't do here or anything like that thank you thanks for illuminating us in that area And I know from our chat before we hit record, you're working in a CAM service. Does that largely kind of look like a UK CAM service? So have you got kind of a psychiatry, if you've got, you know, support workers, if you've got social workers, psychologists, assistants. What does your CAM service kind of broadly look like, Jack?
了解情况很重要，但我幸运地并不觉得我必须时刻保持高度警惕，或者意识到我在英国会做但在这里不能做的特定事情。谢谢你，感谢你在这一领域为我们解惑。我知道在我们录音前的聊天中，你是在CAMHS服务机构工作。那里的工作在很大程度上看起来像英国的CAMHS服务吗？你们有精神科医生、支持人员、社会工作者、心理学家、助理吗？Jack，你的CAMHS服务大致是什么样的？
There's certainly some similarities in terms of they're being an MDT. we have psychiatrists, psychologists, speech therapists, occupational therapists, a paediatrician and then a really large and supportive team of administrators who kind of have a pass with our diaries and kind of generally organizing appointments or so on I guess social work or social workers is maybe an area that we don't have so much cover in or support in and that's something that's maybe developing a little bit more in this country in terms of having an equivalent to social services when it comes to those kind of safeguarding cases. So there are certain processes like that that maybe don't feel as established yet,
在拥有多学科团队（MDT）方面肯定有一些相似之处。我们有精神科医生、心理学家、言语治疗师、职业治疗师、儿科医生，还有一个非常庞大且支持性强的行政团队，他们负责我们的日程安排，通常组织预约等等。我想社会工作或社会工作者可能是一个我们覆盖或支持较少的领域，这是这个国家在拥有类似社会服务机构来处理那些保护性案件方面可能正在发展的一点。所以确实存在一些这样的流程，感觉还没那么成熟，
but are definitely on the radar of the people who are making these decisions and setting up these services. From a sort of day-to-day standpoint, I think there's lots of things that feel similar. We're a big team and we meet weekly to discuss cases just as kind of NHS CAM's team would. People have their own case loads that they manage, which I guess is similar, but perhaps what's different is that there isn't
但绝对在那些做出决定并建立这些服务的人的关注范围内。从日常工作的角度来看，我认为有很多感觉相似的地方。我们是一个大团队，每周开会讨论病例，就像英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的CAMHS团队一样。每个人都有自己管理的病例量，我想这很相似，但也许不同的是，这里没有
maybe as much joint work or kind of observation or shadowing or that sort of thing. You know, if we're working on a case with a psychologist, there might be opportunities to console with each other outside of sessions, but generally everyone has quite busy diaries and so that overlap doesn't happen quite as much. There's a lot more autonomy, I guess,
那么多的联合工作、观察或影子工作之类的东西。你知道，如果我们和一位心理学家一起处理一个病例，可能会有机会在会话之外互相咨询，但通常每个人的日程都很忙，所以那种重叠并不多。我想有更多的自主权，
especially depending on how senior your role might be. So it depends whether you're someone who likes that kind of thing or not. But at times that's great because I feel like, you know, I've got full control over who I'm seeing when I'm seeing and what I'm going to be doing with them. Other times, you know, there's maybe that opportunity for collaboration and teamworking that has to be kind of organized a bit more meticulously than would happen in an office environment where everyone's sharing the same space because we all have our own rooms. operates a bit more like a private setting, I guess.
特别是取决于你的职位有多高级。所以这取决于你是否喜欢那种工作方式。但有时这很好，因为我觉得我对看谁、什么时候看、以及要和他们做什么有完全的控制权。其他时候，你知道，那种协作和团队合作的机会可能需要比在办公室环境中更细致地组织，因为每个人都有自己的房间，不像在办公室里大家共享同一个空间。操作起来更像是一个私人诊所，我想。
I see. It's not like when I was in the NHS and I didn't have my own chair. I didn't have an office, you know, I didn't have my own desk. Like you know where you're going to be and, you know, that sounds ideal. Where are referrals coming in from? Is it kind of GPs? Is it schools? Is it self-referral? What does that typically look like, Jack? That's all of the above, really, because it's a private health care model. and I guess the needs is slightly different here on the whole
我明白了。这不像我在NHS时那样，我没有自己的椅子。我没有办公室，你知道，我没有自己的办公桌。就像你知道你要去哪里，而且，你知道，这听起来很理想。转诊是从哪里来的？是全科医生（GP）吗？是学校吗？还是自我转诊？Jack，这通常是什么样的？真的是以上所有情况，因为这是一种私人医疗模式。而且我想这里的需求总体上略有不同
to maybe the UK waiting lists do exist but they're not as long so if people find out about the service through word of mouth maybe they know someone who's accessed the service or have been told about it then they can get in touch and self-refer similarly with the young people that I'm working with a lot of referrals come in through school perhaps there are difficulties that are arising within the school setting. Otherwise, you know, there are other private services with psychiatry and so on.
与英国相比，等待名单确实存在，但没有那么长。所以如果人们通过口碑了解到这项服务，也许他们认识使用过该服务的人，或者被告知过，那么他们就可以联系并进行自我转诊。同样，我工作的年轻人中，很多转诊是通过学校进行的，也许是在学校环境中出现了困难。否则，你知道，还有其他提供精神病学服务的私人机构等等。
And I think the service has a lot of relationships with prominent psychiatrists in these places that they know to refer to our service because of the different specialties that are on office. So they come from all places, I guess, similar to, I guess, either a private service or an NHS service in the UK. I guess what's different is that it's kind of a. insurance model because it's private health care as well. So what people can access is dependent on the level of insurance they have. That was going to be my next question. Do people self-fund or is it
而且我认为该服务与这些地方的知名精神科医生有很多联系，他们知道因为我们提供的不同专业而转诊到我们的服务机构。所以他们来自各个地方，我想，类似于英国的私人服务或NHS服务。我想不同的是，这是一种保险模式，因为这也是私人医疗。所以人们能获得什么取决于他们拥有的保险水平。那本来是我要问的下一个问题。人们是自费还是
all insurance or organisation funded? Does anyone self-fund or is that so ridiculous, expensive that it's just all insurance? It's more like an American healthcare. No, people do self-funds, whether they have the insurance or not. The insurance may not cover the nature of the work that happens in our service, to kind of traditional medical or physical health services. Some people part fund and part reimburse on insurance. So there's all combination of kind of payment methods is available, really. Thank you. And, you know, are you seeing, so I know you said it's sort of 90% expats there,
全部由保险或组织资助？有人自费吗，还是说那太贵了，以至于全部都是保险？这更像美国的医疗保健。不，人们确实自费，无论他们是否有保险。保险可能不涵盖我们服务中发生的医疗工作的性质，即传统的医疗或身体健康服务。有些人部分资助，部分通过保险报销。所以确实有各种支付方式的组合。谢谢。而且，你知道，你看到的是，我知道你说那里大约90%是外籍人士，
are you seeing kind of Indigenous local people's children? Are you seeing all expat children? so perhaps people that have gone out to move for business, to work for finance, you're seeing their children or the children of, you know, teaching staff that are working in the schools. I'm sure it's a real medley, but it would be, obviously, don't name any names or anything, but just a little bit of an overview of the types of the types of children and young people that you're seeing would be really lovely. Yeah, you're absolutely right. It is a medley. I've had certainly a few young people from, on my case flow, who are Emerati,
你看到的是当地人的孩子吗？你看到的是所有的外籍儿童吗？也许是那些为了生意、为了金融工作而搬过去的人，你看到的是他们的孩子，或者是学校里工作的教学人员的孩子。我相信这是一个真正的混合体，但如果能有一个概述，当然，不要指名道姓，但关于你看到的儿童和年轻人的类型，那会非常棒。是的，你说得完全正确。这是一个混合体。我的病例中确实有几个年轻人是阿联酋人，
and that's been a really nice opportunity to, yeah, understand a bit more about the culture, meeting the parents with these young people and understanding their expectations and being able to adapt my practice. And at times, that's involved using an interpreter to be able to support that if there's kind of any language barriers there, but also there's real variety within the local population
这是一个非常好的机会，可以更多地了解文化，与这些年轻人的父母见面，了解他们的期望，并能够调整我的实践。有时，如果存在语言障碍，这涉及到使用口译员来提供支持，但当地人口内部也确实存在多样性，
in terms of, I guess, their culture and how it intersects with the different cultures that exist here, the education systems that exist here. There's lots of British international schools, American international schools, Russian international schools. There's a lot of overlap. And so, you know, all of the young people that I'm working with who are local to the country have grown up here,
在文化方面，以及它如何与这里存在的不同文化、这里存在的教育体系相交织。这里有很多英国国际学校、美国国际学校、俄罗斯国际学校。有很多重叠。所以，你知道，我工作的所有当地年轻人都是在这里长大的，
you know, will still perhaps conceptualise mental health and the problems that they have through a Western lens because that's what they used to. And I guess there's a spectrum. So on that end to kind of how things might be conceptualised more traditionally here. So that's been a really nice opportunity to work across that spectrum, to understand things slightly differently to what I was used to. And then aside from that, exactly as you said, there's a lot of young people who've come, they've moved, you know, not just once, maybe two or three times within.
你知道，可能仍然会通过西方视角来概念化心理健康和他们遇到的问题，因为那是他们习惯的。而且我想有一个光谱。所以在那一端，到这里可能更传统地概念化事物的方式。所以这是一个非常好的机会，可以在这个光谱上工作，以与我过去习惯的略有不同的方式理解事物。除此之外，正如你所说，有很多年轻人已经搬迁，你知道，在他们的一生中，随着他们的家庭，可能不止一次，也许两三次，
in their lifetime with their families, either through their work opportunities or otherwise. So there's a real mixture in that sense too. I'm always kind of looking out for the nationalities of the young people that are being referred to me in case there's someone new that I get to me from a new background or so on, which is quite a nice aspect. I could imagine in your position,
无论是通过他们的工作机会还是其他方式。所以在这个意义上也有一个真正的混合。我总是留意被转诊给我的年轻人的国籍，以防有来自新背景的新人等等，这是一个非常好的方面。我可以想象在你的位置上，
I might have a little map of the world and kind of picking out little pins of kind of different cultures and nationalities that I'd worked with. And, you know, when I think back to my own experiences of working in CAMs, because I was a CAMS clinician for almost four years when I qualified, I think now when we're looking at modern CAMs now, often the sort of people that are being supported in CAM services now were previously inpatient, because everything is sort of just seems much more severe. And people seem to be getting old, quick and experiencing things that, you know, I'm a mother of Tucho. when I've got a nine-year-old and a 12-year-old. And just some of the things I hear being spoken about
我可能会有一张世界地图，并在上面插上我合作过的不同文化和国籍的小图钉。而且，你知道，当我回想起我在CAMHS工作的经历时，因为我获得资格后做了近四年的CAMHS临床医生，我想现在当我们看现代CAMHS时，通常现在在CAMHS服务中得到支持的人，以前是住院病人，因为一切似乎都严重得多。而且人们似乎老得很快，经历着，你知道，我是两个孩子的母亲，我有九岁和十二岁的孩子。仅仅是我听到的一些被谈论的事情，
just were not on my radar when I was their age at all. I guess it's probably the same for all generations as that we feel like our kids grow up quick. But are you working with a similar level of severity as a UK CAM service? Or is there a bit more of a primary care vibe? Or again, is it a real kind of medley? I'd say it's a mix.
在我那个年纪时根本不在我的考虑范围内。我想这可能对所有世代来说都是一样的，我们觉得我们的孩子长得很快。但你是在处理与英国CAMHS服务相似的严重程度吗？还是有一种更偏向初级保健的氛围？或者，再次，这是一个真正的混合体？我想这是一个混合体。
And I think different clinicians are able to express their preference or maybe their competencies when it comes to working with cases of higher risk than perhaps others. So I had a fair bit of that when I was working in the UK and certainly feel comfortable working with that kind of presentation. So I had a few cases like that, but I wouldn't say it's disproportionate in either direction really to what I was experiencing before. I can't speak too much, I guess, for my colleagues and what they see, but my understanding would be because it's this kind of open system without too many kind of criteria for
而且我认为不同的临床医生在处理比其他人风险更高的病例时，能够表达他们的偏好或能力。所以我在英国工作时处理过不少这种情况，当然也觉得处理那种表现形式很舒服。所以我处理过几个那样的病例，但我不会说它在任何方向上都与我以前经历的不成比例。我不能说太多，我想，关于我的同事和他们看到的情况，但我的理解是，因为这是一个没有太多准入或排除标准的开放系统，
inclusion or exclusion about referrals that anyone could come through the door, really, with any kind of presentation. And it could be, you know, I often try and make the analogy or the comparison with, would this case be seen in a community CAM service in the UK? would they be seen by the GP, would they be seen by something in between or even tertiary services and there can be a lot of differences in that respect.
关于转诊，任何人都可以进门，真的，带着任何表现形式。而且可能是，你知道，我经常尝试做类比或比较，这个病例会在英国的社区CAMHS服务中被看到吗？他们会被全科医生看到，会被中间的某个机构看到，还是会被三级服务机构看到？在这方面可能会有很多差异。
I think cases that perhaps wouldn't meet the Cams threshold in the UK are being seen more frequently here and that's maybe more a circumstance of availability of clinicians and the insurance model, I guess, maybe making that more possible for young people here to be seen if they want to access an early intervention as opposed to something that's a bit later down the line. So, yeah, I think the presentations do vary and there's still that severity and that complexity that comes with working early mental health service. On the whole, I'd say, yeah, there's maybe a bit of a difference to what I've seen and experienced in community and tertiary cam services in the UK.
我认为在英国可能达不到CAMHS门槛的病例在这里被更频繁地看到，这可能更多是临床医生可用性和保险模式的情况，我想，也许这使得这里的年轻人如果想获得早期干预，而不是稍后的干预，变得更容易。所以，是的，我认为表现形式确实各不相同，而且在早期心理健康服务中工作仍然存在那种严重性和复杂性。总的来说，我想，是的，这可能与我在英国社区和三级CAMHS服务中看到和经历的有所不同。
Thank you. I've got just a few quick fire questions that I want to ask you because I've got so many, so many things and we can't possibly do them all justice. But my first one is, can you still get training and support to develop your career when you're abroad? Absolutely. It's in fact a requirement of the license that you have to have to practice out here, that you are continuing your professional development and acquiring, called CME points over here. So there are lots of conferences that happen.
谢谢。我有几个快速提问，我想问你，因为我有太多太多的事情，我们不可能一一详述。但我的第一个问题是，当你身在国外时，你还能获得培训和支持来发展你的职业吗？绝对可以。事实上，这是你在这里执业所需的执照的要求，你必须继续你的专业发展，并获得所谓的CME学分。所以这里有很多会议。
Mordesley Health, the company that I work for, actually have an annual conference, which I was lucky to be able to attend within my first few weeks. The timing fell quite nicely. There's kind of some fantastic speakers there who are working around the country, the region, but also coming from Southland and Mordtly in London. So that's a really nice event where the two kind of worlds collide a little bit.
我工作的公司Maudsley Health实际上有一个年度会议，我很幸运能在入职的前几周参加。时间安排得非常好。那里有一些非常出色的演讲者，他们在这个国家、这个地区工作，但也来自伦敦的南伦敦和莫兹利。所以这是一个非常好的活动，两个世界在这里有一点碰撞。
And then, yeah, we're all allocated a certain number of study days each year that we can use to pursue training as we see fit, whether that's face to face within the country or whether there's kind of online courses that we want to be able to access as well. So there is certainly an opportunity to prioritize that when feels appropriate. So that's, I would have found it difficult to take a role without that kind of assurance, I suppose. So I'm, yeah, grateful that that's an option. Perfect. And visas, you know, have you had help sorting out your visa? Can you stay indefinitely or not? Guide us through that quickly, if that's okay, Jack. For sure. So to be able to work in any of the kind of Emirates, as they're divided up in the UAE, Aberdabee being one, Dubai being a separate. Emirates, that you have to have a license from the Department of Health. So at the point of being offered a role, I was then sent lots of forms to fill in just with kind of information about, I guess, myself, my history and so on, but also contact details for references and identification documents, all the kind of standard stuff you'd expect, plus a few more layers on top, I guess, given the nature of moving abroad. And the HR team took that process and carried out the vast majority of it, and it was just a case of me keeping on my emails in case I needed to update anything or send anything, whatever it might be. The process can be a bit lengthy.
是的，我们每年都会被分配一定数量的学习日，可以根据需要用于进修培训，无论是国内的面授课程，还是我们希望参加的在线课程。因此，在合适的时候优先考虑这一点确实是有机会的。我想，如果没有这种保障，我很难接受这份工作。所以，是的，我很感激有这个选择。太好了。关于签证，你们在办理签证方面得到帮助了吗？你们可以无限期停留吗？Jack，如果可以的话，请简单介绍一下。当然。要在阿联酋的任何一个酋长国工作，比如阿布扎比或迪拜，你必须获得卫生部的执照。在获得录用通知后，我收到了很多表格，需要填写关于我个人、履历等信息，还有推荐人的联系方式和身份证明文件，这些都是你预料之中的标准材料，当然考虑到出国工作的性质，还有一些额外的要求。人力资源团队处理了大部分流程，我只需要留意邮件，以防需要更新或发送任何材料。这个过程可能会比较漫长。
So I suppose if anyone's listening and thinking about making the move here specifically, I would prepare for at least maybe six months from the point of being offered the role to being able to move out here and to start. But once I was here within three weeks or so, I was able to start my role. And in that time as well, in the Emirates or in the UAE, everybody has an Emirates ID. It's kind of form of national identification. everything is kind of tied to that that's your way of setting up a bank account um the utility bills all that kind of stuff it's what people would ask to see if you needed to be identified in any
所以我想，如果有人在听，并且正在考虑搬到这里，我建议从拿到录用通知到搬过来开始工作，至少要预留六个月的时间。但我一旦到了这里，大约三周内就开始工作了。在那段时间里，在阿联酋，每个人都有一个阿联酋身份证（Emirates ID）。这是一种国民身份证，所有事情都与它挂钩，这是你开设银行账户、缴纳水电费等所有事情的方式，也是人们在需要核实你身份时会要求查看的东西。
kind of situation so again the company arranged all of those appointments for me so that i was able to do that as swiftly as possible so it can be a long process um but once you're kind of aware that that's the case it's not so bad it's not so stressful and then my um I guess my right to stay is dependent on having the working visa and my licence. I think everyone's licence maybe is creative for two years. So at the point where that two years is coming to an end, I would have a discussion with the company about whether my intention was to continue or so on, and they would begin the renewal process of that.
在任何情况下都是如此。所以公司为我安排了所有这些预约，让我能尽可能快地完成。所以这可能是一个漫长的过程，但一旦你意识到这一点，就不会觉得太糟糕，也不会感到太有压力。至于我的居留权，取决于我是否持有工作签证和执照。我想每个人的执照有效期可能是两年。所以当两年期限快到时，我会和公司讨论我是否打算继续工作，然后他们会开始续签流程。
It can be a cyclical thing. I see. So it's completely separate to the HCPC. Are you running your HCPC concurrently? Yes, yeah. So I still have membership for that. Perfect. And do many companies offer kind of relocation expenses to help support that? I think it varies massively from company to company and kind of sector to sector or industry to industry here. Moseley Health supported me with flight expenses, which was very helpful.
这可能是一个周期性的事情。我明白了。所以这与HCPC是完全分开的吗？你是在同时维持你的HCPC注册吗？是的，我仍然保留着会员资格。太好了。很多公司会提供搬迁费用来支持这一点吗？我认为这里不同公司、不同行业之间差异很大。Moseley Health为我提供了机票费用，这非常有帮助。
helpful and a hotel for the first two weeks of being here just to kind of get set up and so on, which was right next to the office. So I have the opportunity to go and meet my manager within those first few weeks. It varies otherwise. I mean, one thing to mention, I guess, is that maybe we were going to come onto it anyway, getting somewhere to live, like an apartment or a villa or whatever, there's kind of a mismatch in terms of where, things are out now versus how they might have been 10 or 15 years ago. So a lot of places would expect you to kind of pay a full year's rent up front, which is a bit of a shock when we arrived. I was still being asked and we hadn't prepared for that. And a lot of companies in the past would
而且还提供了刚到这里前两周的酒店住宿，让我可以安顿下来，酒店就在办公室旁边。所以我在最初的几周内就有机会去见我的经理。其他情况则各不相同。我想提的一点是，也许我们本来就会谈到，关于找住处，比如公寓或别墅，现在的情况与10或15年前相比有很大不同。很多地方会要求你预付一整年的租金，这在我们刚到时确实有点震惊。我当时还在被要求这样做，而我们并没有为此做好准备。过去很多公司会
have covered that either without expecting it to be repaid or at least being deducted monthly from someone's salary. So they're moving towards a kind of better system now that suits people who are, you know, being paid month to month and can't necessarily afford to do that. But there are little things like that that a bit of a shock to begin with, and not every company is able to support with that. So, yeah, that's quite a steep learning curve. But it differs massively. So, yeah, I would advise anyone who's going to do their research first on things like that. Absolutely. That does sound like a bit of a shock to the system. And kind of pension and sickness and parental leave and benefits and things like that. Are they largely similar?
承担这笔费用，要么不要求偿还，要么至少从员工工资中按月扣除。所以他们现在正朝着一种更适合按月领薪水、无法一次性支付大额租金的人的体系发展。但确实有一些这样的小事起初会让人感到震惊，并非每家公司都能提供这方面的支持。所以，这是一个相当陡峭的学习曲线。但情况差异很大。所以，我会建议任何打算来的人先做好这方面的调查。绝对是这样。这听起来确实对系统造成了一定的冲击。那么养老金、医疗、产假、福利等这些方面呢？它们与我们在英国经历的相似吗？关于养老金，这里没有养老金制度。我想这取决于人们自己决定是否要在在这里投资，无论是在他们的祖国还是其他地方。但当你离开公司时，通常你会收到一笔补偿金，即使是你自己决定离职，
to that which we'd experience in the UK. So with pension, there isn't a pension system. I suppose that's kind of up to people to decide if that's something they want to invest in while they're here, whether that's back in their home country or whatever. But when you leave the company, generally you'll receive a kind of payoff, even if that's kind of your decision to leave,
这笔钱我想相当于你工作了多少年。所以如果我工作了两年，最后你会得到两个月的工资，你可以随心所欲地投资。至于病假，同样有分配的病假天数，运作方式完全一样。我认为年假、产假等方面的分配可能略有不同。所以，比起我在NHS时有连续工龄等情况，我能选择休假的时间可能更少。但这里有更多的国家法定节假日和银行假日，
that is, I think, equivalent to how many years you've been. been there and you'd have. So if I was there for two years, for example, you'd get two months worth of your salary at the end, which, you know, you could kind of invest how you wish. Sickness, again, the other's kind of sick leave days that you're kind of allocated and then it would work exactly the same. And I think things like annual leave, maternity leave and so on, perhaps a slightly different in terms of the allocations. So I have fewer annual leave days for mind to choose when to take, I guess, than I did in the NHS where I had continuous service and so on. But there are a lot more kind of national holidays and bank holidays and that sort of
等等。所以我认为每年休假的总天数可能差不多，但你选择休假时间的自由度稍微少一点。我认为产假和陪产假可能也比你在英国通常能得到的要短一些。谢谢你，Jack。在你结束之前，还有什么我没问到但你认为对我们有用的吗？我不知道再谈谈我之前所在的服务机构，以及我如何尝试将那种干预模式带到这里，是否有帮助，
things. So I think the number of days you get off from work is probably about the same each year, but you have a little less choice than when you can take them. I think things like maternity and paternity leave are maybe a little bit shorter as well than you would tend to get the UK. Thank you, Jack. Is there anything I haven't asked you that you think would be useful for us to cover before we finish? I don't know if it's helpful for me to talk any more about kind of the service that I was in beforehand and how I'm trying to kind of bring that intervention over here
或者只是让人们了解来到这里是可能的。那太好了，谢谢。是的。我在英国工作的服务机构叫Discover，Discover是一个大约10年前或刚过10年成立的全新服务机构。其理念是将非污名化的心理教育研讨会和干预措施
or just to, yeah, give people a sense of what's possible coming here. It would be great, thank you. Yeah. So the service that I was working for in the UK was called Discover and Discover was a kind of brand new service set up about 10 years ago or just over. And the idea was to kind of bring non-stigmatizing psychoeducational workshops and interventions
引入学校环境，特别是针对六年级学生。也就是16到18岁这个年龄段。在过去的10年里，它得到了巨大的发展，我们在伦敦和东南部地区的许多学校工作，拥有非常强大的合作伙伴关系等等。此外，在那段时间里，还进行了一项同步的随机对照试验（RCT），它提供了一些非常积极的证据，证明这种干预是有效的。所以
into the school setting, particularly for six-form students. So in that 16 to 18 bracket. And over those 10 years, it's developed massively and we were working in lots of schools in London in the South East and has really strong partnerships and so on. And also during that time, a concurrent RCT was, conducted, it provided some really positive evidence that the intervention works. So
能够参与其中真的非常棒，我能够参与服务开发等方面的责任是我非常喜欢这份工作的原因。但从临床技能的角度来看，我想我们所做的事情存在一个上限，因为我们是在提供一种手册化的干预措施，除了这些在学校内进行的一日小组研讨会之外，还有一些护理协调和评估工作。这是我热爱的工作，但我注意到我的许多额外技能，特别是治疗技能，可能变得有点生疏了，我又有了一种多样化的渴望。所以在完成培训并做了四年之后，我想我意识到不要
being a part of that was really great and kind of responsibility that I would get to be able to engage in service development and so on was something I really loved about the role. But from a clinical skills point of view, there were, I guess, there was a ceiling in terms of what we were doing because we were delivering a manualised intervention and it was that plus a bit of care coordination and assessment around these kind of group one-day workshops that were happening within schools. So it's work that I love doing, but I think I was noticing a lot of my additional skills, therapy skills in particular, maybe getting a bit rusty and I had that desire to diversify again. So after four years of finishing training and doing that, I think I was conscious of not maybe
把自己局限住，或者在某个特定领域变得过于专业化，所以我不想因为来到这里而失去这些，感觉好像一切从零开始，开始一个新的培训实习，这通常是我每六个月左右就会有的经历。所以我希望能找到一种方法，将我们在伦敦所做的工作，以及目前正在英国各地推广的工作带到这里，考虑到Moseley Health和Slam之间现有的联系，这里的总经理非常热心，已经了解Discover，并且非常希望实现这一目标，这已经是公司战略的一部分，即扩展
pigeonholing myself or becoming too specialised in a particular area and so I didn't want to lose that by coming here and kind of feeling as if I'm starting from scratch and starting a new placement on training which could often be or something was the experience I had every six months or so. So I wanted to see if there was a way to bring that work that we were doing in London and is currently being disseminated around the UK at the moment over here given the existing links between Morsley Health and Slam and the kind of the managing director here was very keen and was already aware of Discover and really wanted to make that happen and that was part of the company's strategy already was to kind of expand
进入学校系统并建立这些联系。所以这在某种程度上是一个非常好的时机，我决定搬家，拥有了我所拥有的经验。现在，截至今天以及接下来的几周，我们正在敲定一份拨款提案，试图争取一些资金来实现这一目标，并在阿联酋进行一项试点研究，提供这种干预措施，同时也进行大量的共同生产和公众参与（PPI）工作，以进行文化适应，使其满足这里年轻人的独特需求，确保语言是合适的，并符合在这里工作的年轻人的价值观，以及他们对学校干预措施的期望。所以，这是一个机会，
into the school system and to have those connections. So it was a really nice kind of convenient timing in a way that I decided I wanted to make the move, had the experience that I had. And now as of kind of today in the next couple of weeks, we're finalising a grant proposal to try and secure some funding to make this happen and to run a pilot study in the UAE and delivering this intervention, but also doing a lot of kind of co-production and PPI work to adapt it culturally so that it meets the unique needs of the young people who are here to ensure I guess the language is appropriate and that it aligns with the values of the young people that are working here and the things that they're looking for from a school-based intervention. So it's, you know, an opportunity
对于我这个职业阶段的人来说，如果没有这次搬迁，可能不会出现这样的机会，尽管我所在的团队中发生着这些令人惊叹的事情。这一切都是在国王学院（Kings）和后台的研究团队的支持下进行的。所以来到这里，给了我一种许可，让我可以说，这就是我能提供的，我们如何实现它？然后有一个很棒的团队，他们有专门的研究时间和临床专业知识，以及与学校的关系，希望能够实现这一目标。
that may not have come along for someone at my stage in my career, I guess, without potentially making this move as much as there are these amazing things happening in the team I was in. It was all kind of happening with Kings and with a kind of research team in the background. So by coming here, it's given me that license, I guess, to say, this is what I have to offer, how can we make this happen? And then there's a fantastic team of people who have dedicated research time and clinical expertise, relationships with schools who can hopefully make this happen.
所以这确实是来到这里的一个真正的激励因素，也是让这次搬迁顺利进行的原因。是的，听起来你正在获得一些非常棒的重要经验，并做着一些重要的工作，比如服务开发。当你对某件事感到非常兴奋时，真的可以激活那种动力，不是吗？如果有人在听这个节目，心想，哦，我还没有获得资格，我还没有参加临床培训，
So that's been a real kind of motivating factor for coming here and also for just making the move work in general. Yeah, it sounds like you're getting some really great important experience and doing some important work but kind of service development. And when you're really excited about something, that you can really get that drive activated, can't it? If someone's listening to this and thinking, oh, I'm not qualified yet, I'm not on clinical training,
是否会有机会让某人去担任，例如，助理心理学家或PWP？你知道答案吗？也许你不知道，没关系。但如果有人在想，我该如何从更早的阶段参与进来，这是一个选择吗，你知道吗？助理心理学家在这个国家是一个相对较新的角色。我认为即使在我们的服务中，这也是过去一两年内开发的一种非常创新的系统或设置，这些职位是为阿联酋人保留的。所以我的理解是，如果有人是本科毕业生，他们想要一个助理心理学家的职位，但他们想搬到这里，我不确定这些职位现在是否开放。但这里有一些大学
Would there be opportunities for someone to go and be, for example, an assistant psychologist or a PWP? Do you know the answer? Maybe you don't, that's okay. But like if someone's thinking, how can I get involved from an earlier point of view, is that an option, do you know? So assistant psychologists are a relatively new role within the country. And I think even within our service, it's quite an innovative system or sat-up that's been developed in the last. year or two and those positions are protected for um um arirates so my understanding is if someone was a post undergrad and they wanted an AP role but they wanted to move here i'm i'm not too sure if those positions are available right now um but there are some kind of uh there are some universities here
有研究部门，我想如果这对有抱负的心理学家感兴趣的话，肯定会有一些基于研究的角色。除此之外，老实说我不太确定。我不知道是否还有其他类似的角色或在其他部门的角色可以计入培训要求。但幸运的是，助理心理学家的角色仍然非常新。所以，是的，我不确定未来是否会改变。好的，谢谢。
to have research departments and i imagine there would certainly be some kind of research based roles if that was something that interested in this farring psychologist who's thinking about it. Beyond that, I'm not too sure to be honest. I don't know if perhaps there are roles with similar roles or within other sectors that might count towards the kind of requirements for training. But fortunately, AP roles are still very new. So, yeah, I'm not sure if that will change in the future. Okay, thank you.
只是好奇。是的，人们可能会听着想，这听起来不错。给我分一杯羹，但听起来目前确实优先考虑合格的专业人士，并且无论如何都支持他们更容易地被欢迎进入这个国家。如果任何听众或观众有我没有问到的问题，Jack，请务必在YouTube或Spotify的评论区告诉我们。你也可以在那里进行问答。如果你觉得Jack再回到播客会有帮助，如果你认为你有其他问题或我没有很好地盘问他的其他角度，
Just a wonderment. Yeah, people that might be listening thinking, this sounds good. Give me a slice of this, but it sounds like actually qualified professionals are prioritised currently and kind of supported with being welcomed more easily into the country anyway. If anyone listening or watching has any questions that I haven't asked, Jack, please do let us know in the comments on YouTube or on Spotify. You can do Q&A on there as well. If you'd find it helpful for Jack to come back on the podcast, if you think you've got other questions or other angles that I haven't done a very good job of grilling him on.
也请务必提出建议。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈，Jack。希望你周末安排了一些可爱、户外和海滩的活动。谢谢你，Marian，是的。我会确保去户外活动，充分利用它。请务必这样做。再次感谢你的时间。保重。
Please do suggest that as well. Thank you so much for your time in speaking with us, Jack. I hope you've got something lovely and outdoorsy and beachy scheduled for your weekend. Thank you, Marian, yes. I'll make sure I get outdoors and make the most of it. Please do. Thank you again for your time. Take care.
谢谢。非常感谢你抽出时间观看或收听。我喜欢听你们的反馈，以及你们对这一集的看法，也再次感谢Jack博士抽出时间与我们交谈。如果你想了解更多关于现实生活中临床心理学家的故事，以及是什么促使他们进行培训及以后的经历，你可以查看《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书。描述和节目说明中有链接。
Thank you. Thank you so much for your time in watching or listening. I love hearing from you and about what you. thought to this episode and thanks also again to Dr Jack for his time in speaking with us. If you'd like to learn more about the stories of real-life clinical psychologists and what took them to training and beyond, you can do so by checking out the Clinical Psychologist Collective Book. There's a link in the description and in the show note.
如果你已经读过了，欢迎留下你的评论。如果你喜欢成为我团队的一员，并且想支持我作为创作者，如果你考虑加入播客会员，我会非常感激。该会员可在YouTube、Apple Podcasts和Captivate上直接获得。再次强调，描述中有链接。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，我想你会喜欢这个有抱负的心理学家会员资格，它获得了极好的评价，并为人们的职业生涯做出了惊人的贡献。
If you've already read it, I would welcome your reviews. If you love being part of my gang and you want to help support me as a creator, I'd be so grateful if you consider jumping into the podcast member. which is available on YouTube, on Apple Podcasts and directly through Captivate. And once again, there are links in the description. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you are an aspiring psychologist, I think you will love the aspiring psychologist membership, which gets fantastic reviews and is doing amazing things for people's careers.
如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我叫Diakalala Amuja。我是一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我叫Diakolola Amuja。我是一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。Marion博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中非常有帮助。由于我计划在英国继续研究生学习，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格的和正在培训的临床心理学家的经历。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guys. My name is Diakalala Amuja. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. My name is Diakolola Amuja. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK D-KLincide application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists.
各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。我叫Diakalala Amujam。我是一名来自爱尔兰的心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。Marion博士的书《临床心理学家集体》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中非常有帮助。由于我计划在英国继续研究生学习，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格的和正在培训的临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
The various narratives were my favourite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK D-Klinci application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。